and bring out your favorite georgia song
because that's what we're focusing on
today breaking news from georgia where
democrats
have picked up at least one senate seat
in the state's highly charged runoff
election
cbs news projects the reverend rafael
warnock has defeated republican
incumbent kelly loffler making him
georgia's first
black senator the other contest is too
close to call
democrat jon ossoff has a razor thin
lead over republican senator david
perdue
just over 16 thousand votes this is
where the senate
currently stands democrats need to win
both
races to gain control vice president
kamala harris
would be the tiebreaker senior national
correspondent mark strossman is in
decatur georgia
just outside atlanta atlanta with last
night's results mark good morning
good morning anthony here in dekalb
county election officials will resume
counting thousands of ballots this
morning
17 georgia counties are still tallying
their final numbers
and georgia's secretary of state says we
should all know more
by noon today we prove that with hope
hard work and the people by our side
anything is possible
democratic candidate reverend rafael
warnock said he's headed to the senate
to work for all
georgians but incumbent kelly lefler
still sees a path to victory
and promised to keep fighting we have
some work to do here
this is a game of inches we're going to
win this election
we're going to save this country that's
right
that's right the race between incumbent
republican david perdue
and democrat jon ossoff is even tighter
4.6 million
georgians cast ballots in these critical
races that will determine control of the
senate
the coronavirus pandemic and its
economic impact
mattered most to voters a cbs news exit
poll found
more than half of voters said they
experienced financial hardship
due to the pandemic more than 340
million dollars were poured into the
races over two months
despite president trump's baseless
claims of election fraud in georgia
in the presidential election there's no
way we lost georgia there's no way
the rig that was a rigged election
cbs news found seven in 10 georgia
voters felt confident
the votes cast in this election will be
counted fairly
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger we're a very competitive
state
and we obviously have big turnout and
both parties have fought hard
you know to get their vote out and so we
just have to wait and see how this all
shakes out
election officials told us there's still
more than 27 thousand
early votes left to be counted but they
added that this overall count is going
much faster than it did november
because the runoff ballot was so much
shorter
gail mark thank you